[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
we should go into business with the rock
yeah what should we what could we do
with the rock
let's pitch a movie let's come up with a
movie from eu and the rock okay
yeah okay
what kind of movie what kind of movie do
you want to do let's let's work it
backwards what do we want to see the
rock has and what do we want to see you
as and what do we want to see bird has i
want to be a failure okay
i want to be a failure whatever i am i'm
failing i'm in prison let's okay let's
start there i'm in prison i'm in prison
okay i'm in prison in
in uh in hungary
or in budapest you have to be overseas
for this i'm i'm just pitching i'm high
i don't have any rules in my brain oh
yes dude oh you have a [ __ ] yes
please dude good job annie this is the
greatest episode we've ever done
all right i'm in prison in china oh
because we went over sales uh tickets
right so we're gonna incorporate buys a
lot of tickets yeah yeah yeah so i'm in
prison in china okay okay
and uh
it's a big deal
oh do we play our real selves
it's up to you
do you want to play what do you tell me
who your character is i'm going to play
bert i'm only good at playing bert i
feel like i feel like there's got to if
you're in if you're in prison there's a
great tie-in to me either being
an attorney or somebody from the state
department right that makes sense that
that's who would be coming to see you
okay a chinese prison so then we're
characters okay
we're characters i'm in prison you're my
attorney
and and you are a mess okay we're gonna
grow your hair out we're gonna grow your
hair we're gonna give you a mustache
okay
okay
yeah
uh i am in really good shape in this
movie okay but i'm in prison in china
for like doing something liberal like
standing up for women right yeah so i'm
in chinese movies by the way not going
to play in china just so you know we
just lost the whole box office that you
wanted
i'm okay i'm okay about this i'm in
prison in china for beating up a tibetan
monk
there we
yeah yeah they're back
the rock
the rock
is in prison with me
he's in prison with me
and he plays point wow you should be in
prison too
okay yeah falling apart
okay me you and the rocker in prison
yeah
for separate things it'd be weird
like how did you get in here man in this
chinese prison
i think that we should have arrived in
china together
[Music]
what are you doing in chinese
so that's the movie
we gotta get out of a chinese prison
i've been thinking about
razzle dazzling my pants yeah like
really going hard with pants really
going hard with pants like like post
malone uh dove prints red leather i got
a pair of red leather i did a whole
photo shoot put your [ __ ] phone on i
did i did you have [ __ ] going on today
no no no it's not like [ __ ] jesus
yeah yeah
one eight hundred got junk shows up and
tom drops the podcast
because it's because he's the only one
that can translate between his maid and
his [ __ ] guy joined guys
[Laughter]
we could make a [ __ ] movie in a
heartbeat can i tell you my latest pitch
for a movie yeah ready ready we can
crowdfund this on kickstarter okay make
our own [ __ ] movie here here's the
pit it's a working title it's called fat
astronauts
okay okay me and tom are sent to space
because they're going to start building
moon colonies
on the moon colonies on the moon but
right they want to know how many to
build and they're going to sell them to
regular americans like me and tom
so they send us up to the space station
with all the things we like
booze food weed porn stars and they're
like we want to see if your lifestyle
translates to space living or if you die
right and we get up there and we find
out we [ __ ] love it we don't want to
come back we sabotage it so they can't
get us out so that we're locked up do we
go up there with porn stars or they send
the porn stars later dude we're on the
rocket we're drinking cocktails we're
like like in the space shuttle or
whatever i haven't worked out like the
whole yeah
i'm in on this yeah it's like the movie
away the news is there like that scene
to when we go to nasa and they're like
are you guys here to like fix the
the toilets yeah and then we're like no
they're they're sending us up and then
they're like you're way too fat to be
sent just like you have to be in really
good shape and then like a higher up
goes it's a new program we're sending
real fat people up or sending bad people
with drinking problems up there we want
to most americans are like these guys
yeah this is most americans and if we're
going to make space colonies we're not
going to sell it to athletes and then
we're going to sell to people who want
some who have plantar fasciitis and want
some weight off their feet and one of
the one of the uh engineers has to turn
and be like these guys these are guys
are way too fat for this and they're
like it's okay it's okay they're
probably gonna die oh we gotta do two
bears one cave national snoop day yes
where everyone smokes blunts in beds
puts scarves on their head
and listens to a snoop dogg playlist of
just great [ __ ] mute oh you know what
we could do what we could do
two bears one cave live all right
two bears one cave live with snoop right
oh yeah
with snoop
and we'll do it early
we'll take this and we'll put a bed in
here well already i think snoop's gonna
be like we're all in the same bed
i don't think he would like that but
what we do is we just have a playlist
and snoop is like the dj and he does the
playlist yeah and we're all smoking
blunts and everyone can go wake up and
they can play
like wake up with us and hit that
playlist
and then just chill like you know like
like like the watch i'm a little buzzed
i'm way too buzzed i'm losing my power
right now
i still feel it
where
everyone gets that playlist so then you
can
you can do it at your leisure and you
can do it on repeat you can save it so
then one morning when you're like man
i'm having a [ __ ] up day i want to do
a waking bag with snoop tom and bert
it's like almost something that's like a
treat for you all the time yeah so then
you go i want to listen to great music
they can listen to the best music snoop
pics the playlist and miu and tom and me
and snoop are all smoking blunts and
listen to that i love it i love it this
is [ __ ] great oh let's talk about
what branding we can do for you uh okay
like what what okay oh this is a
brilliant transition so the rock's got
tequila right alcohol will be a natural
fit for me definitely kind of think
what if i created a place
to fix your body
meaning all the damage you do we take
you in it's not rehab it's it's it's
more like a like a like a pit crew like
a yeah and we just we bring you back to
levels we make a detox kind of thing
detox we put you under you you having a
detox business is a good business idea
that's a good idea yeah because
you know what your actual selling point
is is not
your partying it's my recovery it's your
my recovery is [ __ ]
and that's what's different than
everybody's you actually have
credibility with recovery i'm in
recovery means i'm [ __ ] just here for
a couple days yeah so i can get back out
on the road yeah
this is a [ __ ] genius yeah if i did a
recovery business
oh it's [ __ ] brilliant best that ever
if you like this video you want to see
more funny comedians we're featuring a
new up and coming comic on our instagram
every single day go check it out right
now link and buy we're sending everyone
these free stickers
uh houston to space shuttle two is tom
there
yeah this is tom
we're getting a reading that there's
come everywhere
uh yeah i've been jacking off a lot
sorry i didn't know where to put it i've
been blowing it into the walls
we're sending porn stars up to help you
out
so fat astronauts and then you ready for
the fourth act the third act whatever
yeah
we block it so that we don't have to
come home and then at the end
we've got to come home and save earth
earth
wait i want to wait why do we have to go
back to save roof i don't know
you know
really
there could be a funny scene i got that
of a funny scene you go like you used to
they're like and you're crying and
you're like
tom killed all the porn
and you see floating like hot porcelain
but they're dead floating around your
camera's not on and you see me lick my
thumb and wipe blood off the screen
because there's blood everywhere i need
to know where the wipes are
fat astronauts fat astronauts is funny
do you know what i was gonna do for
black history month what i was gonna
petition no
i was going to do 28 podcasts
with
each a black person do 28 and every day
release them to celebrate black history
month how'd that plan go it didn't go
well because
leanne just very quickly goes why
wouldn't you just have black people on
normally and i went
what do you mean she was like why
wouldn't you just make an attempt to put
more black people on your podcast and i
was like
that's a good call i was like yeah i
guess i was like here i am making a
stunt out of black history month as
opposed to so i called donnell he's on
my podcast this week
i should have never gotten a car i
really should have never gotten a car
and i actually thought about that i was
like you know why don't we put out um
oh this is fun i love when you do this i
love when you do this let's put out
uh a message yeah who in la would like
to be bert's full-time driver
i'm not opposed to this i know now look
we're gonna vet somebody that can't be a
[ __ ] lunatic obviously i tell you
today i was like we want a safe driving
record no more than one or two duis in
the past and then
um
age range i i got a better idea okay so
hooters used to have an airlines right
hooters hooters yeah so hooters had an
airlines there are still hooters planes
out there i'm certain of it okay hooters
i'm talking to cameron right now hooters
if you would like a sponsorship on two
bears one cave
please find me from la to austin every
week to do this goddamn podcast
right yeah they've got to have hooters
planes there they are right and you know
planes last forever they don't go bad no
so
get a hooters plane yeah they're gonna
do it's not milk it's a plane yeah yeah
no but the planes last for [ __ ] ever
i know and so look at this they've got
hooters planes all over the [ __ ]
world
hooters i first of all i'm a big fan of
your food i've always have been a vanity
food
i'll do whatever you guys want we'll
read an ad on here we'll promote hooters
for in perpetuity while tom lives in
this [ __ ] city
and
all you got to do is just get me a
hooters plane to fly me back and forth
right yeah perfect and then we'll
obviously bring food on the plane i'll
eat food on the plane we'll do
commercials on the plane social media on
the plane whatever the [ __ ] you want
it's just i would love to go fly on a
hooters i was like how could it be if
you roll up
you got a hooters plane a bunch of
hooters [ __ ] which is standing
outside they're like what's up b-man
you're like hey and they've got pitchers
of beer you're gonna play with a pitcher
of beer and then they go bert buffalo
shrimp i go you know the b man and so we
start murdering buffalo shrimp right
i gotta go we got you breaded we got you
unbreaded we got your fries we got the
flounder sandwich the grouper sandwich
we got everything bert you ready and i'm
like we're gonna [ __ ] have a blast
and then we roll in here deep right i
got five hooter waitresses with me and
we just come in we're like hey guys
let's bang a couple out right and then
we bang a couple out right and i'm like
ladies back on the hooters plane and we
fly to tampa or wherever la whatever
okay
that's a sincere pitch to hooters if
hooters is into it i know there's gotta
be they don't have the planes they've
gotta they've gotta have a guy who's in
charge of hooters that's got one [ __ ]
plane there's a guy holding on to one
[ __ ] plane
you know that right okay you know
there's one [ __ ] guy who still wears
jean shorts who's got one [ __ ] plane
yeah and he's like god damn it he
[ __ ] knows i got a plane
[Laughter]
we'll do a hooters read was it's got to
be it's got to be dude for the year i
mean come on why don't we reach out to
hooters
okay
but here's the deal i don't want this is
what i want
hooters is the only thing i can think of
that makes sense i want to get like a
really nice
like linen suit but get my face
embroidered all over it
what a cool idea
i'm really into tracksuits right now i
was thinking about getting motorcycle
getting into motorcycles
very seriously really very seriously
what's stopping you uh just death
but i mean you maybe you won't die just
do it probably ooh ceramic and poetry
pottery oh i was like why would they put
those together
you need to work with me or against me
okay
[ __ ]
hooters is our [ __ ] deal okay
mcdonald's hooters we need big brakes
budweiser let's go to budweiser yeah uh
[ __ ] uh any alcohol response like
cheetos has to happen tito's is located
here why don't we do it see if there's a
tito's jet let's do i say what we do
what if we did a match up the way rogan
does uh does ufc what if we did a show
together at a nascar event
like we do it
and then we go to the nascar event and
then we come home and let's go to a big
one like daytona or talladega you want
to go to there do a show there we're
going to do a show the night before so
we can deficit fund our trip
and then
go do then go to
the nascar the next day yep
and why don't we do why don't we even do
a two a live two bears one cave up the
way they have their commentators hey
it's burt and tom we're here at
talladega we can do it and we'll live
stream it we could do it it would be
[ __ ] awesome
you know what i'm gonna say
hmm
would i say at the same time
you know our brains are on
yeah
one
two three crayons two bears no
oh two bears racing
dude this is the greatest episode we've
ever done
two bears racing would be two bears
racing two bears racing
ladies and gentlemen i'm pleased to
announce
me and tom segura's joint venture
into the next
uh
arm
of our
enterprise
and we are very pleased to announce tom
once you make the announcement uh i will
be uh very happy
to be uh announcing that i'll be
competing
in a amateur
uh race under the two bears racing
banner under the two racing
company company we're starting a company
yes and
my
uh new uh
pit crew chief is uh bert crusher god
damn it he's running those tires too hot
right i am the guy i am the [ __ ] guy
and you're my racer you're younger than
me i'm more knowledgeable i've been
around the track a couple times
this is [ __ ] genius what's this guy
what wait
dwarfism oh dandy and some dandy is from
zaha wait what is that hold on why would
you skip past this nadav
dandism
yeah yeah it's not just about the
clothes it's the pursuit of an elegant
lifestyle and it really is that a
lifestyle what begins as a hobby
collecting grooming and decorating can
quickly turn into passion and then into
a lifestyle dandies don't generally
consider it a hobby i'm a dandy becomes
who they are
and it is exhibited in all aspects wait
i want to explore this
let's get into dandism yeah dude
call me a dandy
shut the [ __ ] up what is okay so it's
just
it's just like being
well groomed at all i think it's like
gay but not sexually
does that make sense wait go out of
images go just into the all results you
know what i mean
yeah [ __ ] that type in dandy comedian
and see if i can take
wait what is th what is this explo what
is that one say there yeah yeah click
that
excessively concerned about his clothes
and appearance a fop a fop informal
something or someone of exceptional or
first-rate quality
oh wait go bound is dandy a slur i like
that because i've been saying it for the
past five minutes
is dandy a derogatory term
the word danny is jock often sarcastic
adjective being fine or great when used
in the form of a noun it refers to a
well-groomed and well-dressed man but
often
to one who is self-absorbed this is
perfect it could be a great dandy yeah
but we gotta take you shopping
immediately i'm buying dandy clothes
right now okay let's buy i'm gonna buy
dandy clothes on on amazon how do you
feel about just being in like suits and
stuff
you hate it yeah
how are you gonna be a great dandy
so so here we go we start tom on some
short dirt tracks in in texas we're
gonna have a big live event when we do
it
right nadav
yep can you can you set that up where we
can i would like to stream
tom's entire race so it's like it's like
a it's like a mma fight right
so if i was in an mma we could set up
mma fights and then we could stream it
much like jake paul but instead what
we're gonna do is we're gonna stream
like jake paul maybe we hook up with
snoop and triller oh let's get snoop
let's get snoop to commentate with us
you actually know snoop i do know snoop
i'm a bad [ __ ] we we get snoop
to commentate with us and we we
stream the whole event at a short track
short dirt track in texas so you're home
i want you to be home and then and then
we do a big event
and then maybe we and i don't think we
bring i think you race against the
locals we got a red no it's gotta be an
amateur race bro like that's what it is
yeah what do you mean like other people
who just like are yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah we'll get them and then we'll
get we'll get you a oh no i'm getting
you for your birthday i'm getting a
[ __ ] race car
oh my god
wait when's your birthday april 16th
that's after that's before july
oh i'm getting tom a race car i'm
getting you a race car
oh this is the greatest thing ever dude
please i'm getting you a race car that's
the thing is it doesn't have to be
like find a race car in that price point
find one
you know what i mean don't don't is
there amateur formula one
no you don't want to get one of those
you don't want to go throw up
no just look for like we'll get we'll
get a race car i promise that's a great
idea this is a [ __ ] great idea now i
have to worry about your birthday
present
i'll get you a [ __ ] race car i get
you a race car yeah you know what three
we need uniforms there is formula ford
formula four i should have dated a half
peruvian half white chick you can still
do it
walking lunges with chains i use the two
chains over there which equates to
almost a hundred pounds
um around my
fatal neck
and then we'll move over into look we
even laughed at the same time outside
wait hit pause me and rock laughed at
the same time we're so similar here's
why we're similar right
here's why we're like
i have to hold myself back from doing
videos like this because i know no one
wants to see it out of me but every time
i work out i want to do please start
doing these i'm going to do these today
i'm going to do this today i'm going to
do this exact video i wish i had a
respect shirt i wish i had a respect
shirt because i literally tom every time
i work out i want to do exactly this
video it's so who i am
it is who you are it's totally who you
are and i go and like and especially
like really talk about it like you're
yeah today today all right guys here's
what we're gonna do and isn't there like
a isn't there a second picture in this
feed like the post workout yeah i'll do
that done done i'm doing that today look
at his legs
look how vascular
like it's oh i didn't know you're
supposed to flex he's got but he's
that's got to be that's got to be the
end of the that's end of the workout 40
body fat yeah his body is [ __ ]
ridiculous yeah i heard he's not that
fast i bet i could him beat him in a
foot race oh yeah i bet i could beat him
in a foot race i bet i could i bet i
could be the rock in the foot let's okay
ready ten things i could beat the rock
in
okay foot race easy easy easy okay type
in the rock running i bet it looks like
i bet it looks like they're not his
original body parts really i bet type in
the rock running okay
um i could beat them in a mile i could
beat him in i could beat him on any foot
race i think you know what i wanted to
do i wanted to play a game where we
pulled up pictures of our ex-girlfriends
yeah and just kind of picked them apart
it's probably not a good
i like where your head's at but
i'll see you my first girlfriend yeah
like girl girlfriend you're in high
school with her yeah i mean she she
could say whatever she wants she was she
was younger than i was i was 18 she was
like 16 15. 13 yeah 13 12. yeah and this
back by the way when that was totally
legal i was 17 i was 17.
it was never i guess legal but it was
like not like her mom was cool with it
my parents were cool with it yeah i
would love to know
at my dick at my smallest yeah
how much bigger it gets because a
thousand is probably too big
[Music]
you